découvrir ses droits à la retraite à
partir du service en ligne c'est
l'exercice proposé au député yvelinois
par la caisse nationale de l'assurance
vieillesse de montigny le bretonneux
c'est mission l'accompagnement des
futurs retraités par rapport à leurs
droits et le paiement des pensions
bien évidemment les retraités n'ont pas
à s'inquiéter c'est déjà fait voilà donc
là les droits sont acquis la pension est
acquise les futurs retraités se pose des
questions effectivement là pour
l'instant on les rassure c'est à dire si
la réglementation constante ceux qui
veulent partir partent
et c'est peut-être les plus jeunes en
fait pour lequel l'enjeu et est
véritablement les concernent
cette visite des parlementaires lrm et
modem un moment de préparation des
travaux autour de la réforme des
retraites actuellement en concertation
après la remise du rapport de jean paul
delevoye alors ambassadrice des
retraites s'est déjà présentée aux
citoyennes et aux citoyens les
réflexions que nous avons conduite avec
le haut commissaire qui a été nommé donc
jean paul delevoye qui vient de
rejoindre l'exécutif
ce qui est intéressant dans la réforme
de le voit c'est finalement de dire si
une réforme qui est globale on
transforme le système en profondeur on
fonctionne sur la base d'un régime à
points en simplifie ya plus de régimes
spéciaux je pense qu a pas de thème
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on a le temps de
la consultation avec les partenaires
sociaux
et puis surtout dire que c'est une
réforme globale qui permettra de
garantir à tous les français quel que
soit leur âge aujourd'hui qu'ils
toucheront une retraite à la fin de leur
carte officielle prise en compte de
l'âge ou des trimestres de cotisation
pour le départ à la retraite c'est l'une
des interrogations de cette réforme dans
les yvelines en 2018 l'âge moyen des
départs à la retraite
atteignez 63 ans